earlier today we had an incident where
civilian infrastructure including a
kindergarten were hit
the ukrainian foreign minister already
said the heavy weapons had been fired at
estonia luhanska and was a serious
violation of ceasefire agreements in the
last few minutes too we've heard from
the ukrainian president the shelling of
a kindergarten instantiate lukanska by
pro-russian forces is a big provocation
it is important that diplomats and the
osce remain in ukraine their monitoring
activities are an additional deterrent
we need an effective mechanism for
recording all cease-fire violations uh
the osce the organization for security
cooperation in europe
and also the ukraine's joint forces
operation
which monitors shelling overnight
have suggested uh about an hour and a
half ago that 29
shells fell that's from midnight as i
said overnight 27 of them uh including
weapons that are banned under the minsk
agreements are basically uh heavier
caliber weapons and apparently that does
happen all the time but that's compared
to five shells yesterday and zero a
month ago for example so a real uptick
um the corollary of that though is the
counter claim something we've heard so
much about and it's been reported
that a sessions about shelling were also
made by representatives of the
self-proclaimed luhansk people's
republic so russian-backed separatists
it said ukrainian forces had used
mortars grenade launchers and a machine
gun in four separate incidents in
on thursday um worth bearing in mind
this is an area of conflict so these
claims do happen all the time so uh that
is the latest on that incident but um as
the nato secretary general was asked uh
everybody very aware of the issue of
false flags for example hitting civilian
areas
and so
we need to keep a closer on that
obviously